[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been lucky to have chris sims from
pro football talk
live joining us for most of the season
former nfl quarterback
if i had talked to you an hour before
the super bowl chris
tell me what you think what would happen
in the game what would you have said
i would have told you that
if the bucks wanted to win the football
game
they would have to play a similar style
of football to like the 1990 giants
against the buffalo bills and i would
have told you
i'm not so sure that still will work i
worry about their ability to stop the
kansas city passing game
and i think the kansas city chiefs will
win the game that's what i would have
told you before the game
i was curious about the adjustment
adjustments or the lack thereof that
kansas city had we know that tampa made
adjustments
from the last time they played it felt
like kansas city
thought that they could do what they did
you know the previous time chris so
right i mean that was kind of strange
there what adjustments could the chiefs
have made
uh you know in the first half or
certainly the second half
right well i mean first off i think you
bring up a good point that's the
psychosis i think of like when you've
lost to a team right
uh or a team had two teams that played
each other earlier in the year and now
it's a super bowl the team that lost
i do think has the advantage in that
because they go wait we gotta change
something right dan
what we did the first time is not gonna
work and we might have to
oh gamble and take a risk here and there
the team that won of course comes going
hey we can still do a lot of the stuff
we did first
time around it all worked so let's stay
and keep some of that game plan there
so that is the you know some of the
psychosis you could fall into the trap
there
what i thought we would see more of of
course i was worried about the pass rush
of the bucks and all of that
we know that but what i've seen down the
stretch of the year
is a lot of teams have tried to do what
tampa did to the chiefs last night
but the chiefs have still had a
phenomenal short passing game
and other ways to get the ball moving
that way then to go wait okay you want
to play all this coverage
all right well we're picking you apart
with a short passing game
now you need to start coming up and
covering us a little tighter and then
they take shots down the field
but that was the greatness of bulls
defense i think
one the front four got there for the by
themselves for the most part of the
night
they brought a few blitzes real early
just to make kansas city think about it
and then played coverage from there on
out and i think the other big thing too
dan sorry for the long
answer is the two middle linebackers in
the middle of the field allowed them to
play that style of football because then
they can play safeties deep
protect the sidelines all right now
we're vulnerable in the middle
but we got two super freaks in here who
we think can handle kelsey to a degree
and
that's really the brilliance of what top
bulls did who
should have been the mvp
i i think it's i it's hard for me not to
go with brady okay you know i
i think i think realistically you know
devon white i think is a guy that
should have been in that conversation
with watching the football game
you know but i think when you're gonna
take one person player even though it
wasn't like
jaw-dropping i still think brady
everything he did with that team still
playing pretty damn good last night
is still unbelievable i do think the
story of the game
is the buccaneers defense but i think if
you give an mvp to anybody you give it
to tom brady
could they have given it to todd bowles
i
i i mean most valuable person right
i hear you but but i mean i i don't
think you can
this will be remembered for our lifetime
what they did they held the chiefs
without a touchdown in the super bowl
i i agree i wish they could pay more i'm
with you
this it's listen you know me i love
quarterbacks i love them all
but this goes back into our old
conversation and just we
it's like the heisman or the super bowl
mvp your team won the quarterback gets
it
great you know but we've seen like hey
super bowl 42 with that giants defense
eli manning got the mvp i don't know i'd
like to go well
justin tuck and michael strahan were
really unbelievable i do wish there was
another avenue they could pay the
defensive players
a little bit more respect maybe with
some other type of award or a todd
bowles
just to add some importance to what they
did and i brought this up about 20
minutes ago
brady when you have brady you know you
have a chance
right so if i'm a defensive player
offensive player like i
i know that guy won down 28 to three
we always have a chance that confidence
level
cannot be understated with what brady
gives you and
i thought that that was on display that
the buccaneers looked
really really confident yes they did
i mean dan yeah they're really talented
you know
as we saw last night you know they're
they're and i know i came on during the
show earlier in the year and said man
when they play their best ball they look
as good as anybody in the sport
there's just not a lot of weakness to
anything they are wanting any one area
of their football team
we just wondered can they all get it
together and play at a
high level you know with this weird year
and get it done in time
and i would say most times no but that's
where brady comes in to your point i
think
you know he gives everybody the
confidence the polish the work ethic
he likes to fire every under everyone's
butt whether he's saying it with words
or not because they see him working and
they go
i don't want to let him down but why are
the odds that gronk antonio brown and
leonard fournette would all contribute
in a big way
well and to me that's the brady effect
too they're not there if it isn't for
brady
you know that's the other aspect of the
whole thing that i think is just you
you can't quantify it with stats or
anything like that
this team was awesome fournette gronk
antonio brown came there because of tom
brady
and that is special that is what brady
is the ultimate general the ultimate
clutches quarterback ever
um but it was a great team effort and i
think where i really undervalued the
game more than anything
to me dan you know yeah i thought the
o-line for the chiefs will be able to
hold up a little bit better and i think
the other aspect is
patrick mahomes was nowhere near 100
and that was a big aspect of the game
his ability not to be able to really run
full speed or some of those throws he
made where he had to throw the ball away
i would go man five weeks ago he would
have turned the corner there and
threatened the line of scrimmage
and now guys would have had to come up
to him and make a tackle and he would
have thrown a laser by them
that was a big aspect of the game i
think that that we
all could talk about a little bit more
yeah i i thought that that would have
been buffalo's game plan or cleveland's
game plan is to make him run put
pressure on him with that toe
and hit him if you don't sack him hit
him
and they had 24 pressures they hit him
12 times brady got hit twice
and it almost felt like mahomes was back
at texas tech
the officiating in the first half um
how much how much credence do you give
to some questionable calls there i i
don't like any of them listen
the bucks were the better team the bucks
were going to win the damn game no
matter what so i'm not sitting here
trying to make excuses or do anything
like that
i'm just looking as a football fan and
everything we watch through the playoffs
this is to me one of the issues in the
nfl right now
we get the regular season all those were
called past interference all regular
season i wrote
this on twitter last night i just kind
of wrote these are penalties
but the problem is they haven't been the
penalty they haven't been penalties all
playoffs that's where it bothered me
about it
and now it's wait it's four minutes left
in the second quarter
and the show of the game is gonna become
the referees you know on some very ticky
tack questionable calls i thought it's
just one of those moments where i'd go
that hasn't been consistent with what
we've seen in the playoffs just let
these guys play
i thought that was a little bit a little
bit bad on the nfl's part he's chris
sims pro football talk live
co-host should a train a team trade for
carson wins
uh yes well i mean i'll state it first
to go
carson wentz needs to get the hell out
of philadelphia period
he he's in a no-win situation jalen
hurts is still there
so what they brought in coaches that
like you as soon as you play bad the
whole city of philadelphia is gonna go
you stink get the hell out of there
so he's gotta go and i do think hey the
colts chris ballard and company
frank reich has history with them i
would think they have
carson wentz towards the top of their
list as far as acquiring quarterbacks
yeah i just don't know how much you
trade for him
because you are you're taking him it's
like jared goff
you're taking him off your hands you're
taking him off your salary cap
right i was told that the eagles were
asking
too much and that's a couple of
first-round picks and maybe a player
but i i don't know it feels like if i'm
the colts or the bears
i if i'm going in on carson wentz why
don't i go all in on desean watson
listen i hear you i think you make a
good point and what i would want to tell
you dan is go like why would chicago
want carson wentz
why let me to me they're they're playing
with fire with wanting him too
if he doesn't play good they're just
going to go look matt nagy and ryan pace
can't evaluate quarterbacks philadelphia
didn't even want this guy why did we
bring him in here
to me there's too much of a negative
conversation about wence to want to be
in chicago
and i agree with what you're saying they
got to be careful about how much they
asked to trade for him one you're right
about the money situation
you're taking them off the hand because
of that and two listen
there's a negative connotation around
carson wentz right now
so you're taking a little gamble and
taking him on anyways because if it
doesn't work
out everyone's gonna go philadelphia
didn't wanna
why the hell did you guys and that's why
i can understand teams saying we're not
going to give up the house for carson
wentz
any chance drew brees doesn't retire and
if he does
are they set at quarterback well
i would expect drew brees to retire i
mean it's an amazing career
but i think we can all see the skills
have clearly diminished
and and it's he's listen without
you know being shy here he's one of the
negative aspects of their team really
the last few years so i would expect him
to not be there anymore now the
quarterback on their team
yes i think that he's a believer in
taysom hill and i think he really likes
jason
t uh uh you know exactly i couldn't
think of his damn name there
i think he like sean payton likes both
of those guys so yes i think the
quarterback of their team is on their
team right now and they'll try to resign
jameis winston in free agency
hey thanks for coming on this football
season
and uh we appreciate uh your time and uh
what do you do now
well i mean i was gonna say why are you
saying goodbye to me i mean are you
gonna call me in the quarterback draft
or free agency i mean i'm kind of good
at that stuff
i mean jeez i didn't know i just kind of
tossed me into the trash well
this was just sort of a you know hey
thank you the
season ended but i you know we're going
to we're going to call you
okay i promise we'll call you all right
good i'm still in the circle of trust
we're still
friends and the trust tree and all that
um
yeah yeah all right as long as i am with
you the hell with frizzy and the rest of
the career i don't care about that
i can't guarantee fritzy won't bother
you but you know i'll try to keep it to
a minimum
okay thank you man thank you appreciate
it that's chris sims pro football talk
live
co-host